our next guests crowning athletic
achievement is participating in the coin
toss while serving as the honorary
captain for the University of Michigan
against Central Florida in 2016 well
known for running the 40-yard dash at
the NFL Scouting Combine even wrote
these six second barrier ones in 2014 a
proud judge van has mistakenly believed
that they were going to turn things
around for as long as he can remember
and swears this year his alma mater
Michigan will finally beat Ohio State
he's a dear friend of the show even
though he's no Dan big league so the
Rich Eisen show on DirecTV audience
Network channel 239 right after this
show and Rich Eisen joins us on the
program how many years should the NFL
network now we're bowl covering for the
NFL Network
how many 61 six do you remember your
first one because we weren't sure what
yeah we we weren't sure what the NFL
network was when it was we were 11 weeks
old for the first Super Bowl that we
covered which was the end we came up the
Tuesday of week 11 of the 2003 season is
when we launched and so 11 weeks later
it was our first Super Bowl in Houston
Carolina and New England now here we are
for our 16th Super Bowl it's the Rams in
New England and of our 16 Super Bowls is
the 8th that the Patriots are involved
and there had been involved in half of
the Super Bowls that the NFL Network has
covered half we're running out of
storylines with the Patriots now the
Brady says it's 0% yet he's gonna retire
yes what are the storylines for the
Patriots this week I'm open for ideas
Dan I'm willing to take many suggestions
my favorite one as you know because when
we in their business we have some people
who fill the time by coming up with the
most bizarre yet clickable ideas my
favorite one that I'm predicting will
happen is at some point we're going to
get a Brady legacy question that if
loses this game he will just be a mere
five and four in Sybil we'll ignore the
fact that he's in an absurd nine Super
Bowls which we'll never see again with
any quarterback as long as football is
played out of mass we've already done
this with LeBron right the fact that
he's made all these finals and but
what's his record because that business
Jordan is to basketball what Montana is
to football that they were undefeated
so Jordan six and oh and you know Tom or
Montana was four now right my point is
it you know what takes more talent or
what's more impressive if you go there
and you win or the number of times you
go there and I think that we tend to
look at Super Bowl when you lose yes
like that's a really big negative just
getting there is an accomplishment
amazing certainly certainly in this day
and age where there's now the salary cap
rules that were in place when the the
triplets were playing for Dallas that
players come and go and it's amazing the
the lack of first-round picks the
Patriots had four so-called skilled
position players to feed Brady's
offensive juggernaut he just does I mean
he's had Randy Moss and obviously Gronk
or his best players that are gonna go to
the Hall of Fame that we could sit here
and say they'll definitely wind up in
the Hall of Fame one just went last year
well Julian Edelman of course well yeah
I've heard that this weekend that okay
so we started with that poll question
last week where we go would you rather
have Calvin Johnson yes or Julian
Edelman 'he's career and then we've kind
of morphed into is Julian Edelman a Hall
of Famer now I'm seeing columns written
on well you're a trendsetter day thank
you that's sir if that's your point if
that's your point for this you see
brings about around
I just it's alright it's just it's just
their first hour and a half is that
being the first studio audience a week
you just got a there by Friday it's the
same audience staying here I like it
yeah very roomy yes it is very room yeah
it but I don't I don't know I mean that
the conversation this week is in my mind
gonna be all about Sean McVeigh once the
Commissioner is presented with a
microphone in front of him and answers
the question that everyone in New
Orleans has been waiting for what is he
what does he say is that's and that's
the reason why I think he hasn't said
anything I mean when when it's the the
worst I said it's the worst non-call
I've ever seen the only one that comes
close to the worst non-call I've ever
seen and this is gonna go deep into it
here is the 98 World Series between the
Yankees and the Padres and it's bases
full of Yankees in Yankee Stadium Tony
Gwynn is already homered the Padres are
up and Game one of a series that
eventually gets swept in and it's a it's
a 2-2 count
mark Langston on the mound Tino Martinez
at the plate and Langston just grooves
one right over home plate for some
reasons call ball three not strike three
and that Martinez turns the next pitch
around for a grand slam home run because
normally though bad non calls are made
worse by what happens after that you
know when we could sit here and say well
the Padres you know Langston had another
pitch he should have struck him out
instead it's a home run in the same way
that we're talking about well you know
the Saints Saints did get the ball first
and overtime did have chances
it's a terrible non call and so did Bud
Selig come out and say that was a
terrible non call I was just one of the
worst not I mean what what does a
commissioner supposed to say and I know
if I say that on my alarm just an NFL
guy and he's my boss which is true he is
my boss but I I can say whatever I want
as you know and I'm not told what to say
he is going to basically say what maybe
he should have put this out in a
statement just to front-load it for the
week is that you know they're constantly
striving to get better they're
constantly looking at officiating the
you know that was a call that should
have been made what else is he gonna say
you know this whole business of Southern
California is absurd yeah I don't buy
into that I mean it's crazy because cuz
you'd you know you'd think they'd wait
until a hundred and eight seconds
remaining to finally pull off the caper
that they had been cultivating for the
first four quarters essentially of the
game you know like so you know and they
so it is difficult once that's finally
turned as a page and tonight's media
night is gonna be filled with Rams
basically having these questions thrown
into them whether they're legitimately
here is the NFC champion and they will
bristle and they will balk and
somebody's gonna say something
particularly galling to new orleans fans
and that's gonna light up tomorrow's
conversation eventually that's gonna
turn the page and all gonna focus on
Sean McVeigh because he's truly one of
the more dynamic individuals and a total
outlier when it comes to an NFL head
coach in a game like this one
talking to Rich Eisen from the NFL
Network and of course the Rich Eisen
show on DirecTV audience know where
channel 239 that follows this program
would you rather sit down with Bill
Belichick for an hour or Tom Brady for
an hour Oh what Belichick do I get do I
get oh I don't know what you get I know
I mean I don't even know if he knows
what you get no I mean he knows what you
get I mean if he's the one that will
wrack wax rhapsodic about his career
look back not give the proverbial all
I'll look at it when I'm done I'm moving
on to the Rams then I'd want to sit down
with Belichick I mean the amount of
football that this guy knows is truly
unbelievable it's have you seen him
break down film for his local show
in New England have you seen that it's
like it's because he's if he is the
modern-day Lombardi it is this
millenniums version of you know that
famed seal here and it's still there and
he is just breaking down film and it is
remarkable how much he enjoys it and how
how how into it he is and then he put
like playfully makes remarks with Scott
Zoll act which is words I never thought
I'd say no in a microphone but it is
something
that is shows you who he is normally
when you don't get him in front of a
microphone in a massive media setting I
just don't know how effusive he would be
even if he's reflecting back and I go
back to sitting down with Brady prior to
last year's Super Bowl and I said to him
do you think you and coach Belichick
will ever sit down and reflect back on
what you've done and he goes no no and I
like he looked at me like are you
kidding me that that's never going to
happen well cuz I don't think he can
imagine the forum in which that would
happen is it they're gonna be in the
back of a Tring his boat or he and
Giselle go out for a date night with
Bill and Linda who picks up the check I
mean like what does it look like I think
you just go out to dinner yeah I
couldn't then it's all done
they split it they split the chapters
bill reach who reaches who makes the
reach not Brady
that's a poll question Paul yeah I think
Brady that's hot right yeah it's a poll
question that's on fire Brady puts down
Giselle's credit card I think is what
happened well yeah well obviously it's a
business it'll be I would I would just
be curious what that would be like now
you know maybe the only thing I have it
to compare it to is what Keith Olbermann
and I did at SportsCenter it's not like
we sit down and reflect but we never did
that right hey let's sit down and
reflect back on what we did right but
they had individual moments games Super
Bowls where it would be fun to hear it
and but I understand why it would never
happen I think it'll happen unless you
force that remember when the two bills
come together right now I think they'll
get together though one day I mean
honestly the fact that they're back here
at this Super Bowl after what we were we
were discussing last year in Minnesota
okay where it was Bill and Tom and Bob
Kraft and Jimmy G and that whole snake
pit that was apparently developed in the
in in the locker room and in the
facility there and then Brady pleads the
fifth a couple of weeks later you know
with Jim Gray and and now they're back
they're here again you know and that's
their mantra you know we're not going
away or something or whatever they're
saying to put on their put up put on
their sleeve but it two days play the
Tom Brady productionvalue yeah okay well
maybe okay okay Tom you're not an
underdog here maybe's I mean it sounds
funny everybody uses that right I mean
that's it that's the annual some it's
just tough again half of the NFL Network
Super Bowls have been Patriots Super
Bowls it is insane but I chose them to
win the AFC and it's I don't think I was
alone in that regard but you have Brady
who is recorded as saying I'm the
baddest bleep ass bleep er in the world
you're not an underdog if you're saying
I'm the baddest really right I guess
you're trying to have it all possible
ways today look they play the underdog
role and they're trying their best to
continue to play the underdog role and
I'm fine with it but I don't believe it
I'll never forget the witch Super Bowl
when you he was an NBC Super Bowl
Cardinals and Steelers knew and we're
you know I was doing NFL Total Access at
the time for the NFL Network and we
would be teasing who's coming up with a
live shot of whoever was the guest off
to the set walking on the set so it was
Ken Whisenhunt the head coach of Arizona
at the time and Adrian Wilson the
thumper from the back end of the defense
walking on the set and a mic coming up
next
Ken Whisenhunt Adrian Wilson would come
right back so we go to break and he
walks on the scent he looks at me goes
worst team in playoffs huh I'm like what
are you talking about he goes we're the
worst team in the history of the
playoffs huh and I'm like going through
you know how it works you go through
your rolodex you go through all this
well when did I say that how did I say
it was it anything close to saying it I
said nothing like that
I said nothing like that you know who
did Chris Collinsworth said it and he
thought that I said
because he was in such a hole Super Bowl
week rage of we are the underdogs and we
are we are gonna kick some ass here and
and I'm like you know
I didn't say that christed and if you're
gonna scribe that to me can I have his
Emmys as well yeah like what else can I
have of Chris Collinsworth and she was
just you know I mean just in a total
total state of mind that he tried to get
the entire locker room in it's just
tough that the Patriots are trying to
pull this one off I remember when the
Giants beat the Buffalo Bills and I went
to oj Anderson's locker at after the
game and he wouldn't talk to anybody in
the media because he was cursing at us
saying none of you guys picked us to win
right so they just won the Super Bowl
none of you bleep and bleep errs picked
us too and I said I did which I did
right in USA today like they had my my
my prediction along with everybody else
I said well I did say he'd just know he
didn't want it isn't Fitness air no
because then he's gonna have to talk to
me so then I go over to Jeff Hostetler's
locker he had just won the Super Bowl
filling in for Phil Simms and somebody
taken a razor blade and and they had
carved up his suit and I didn't
understand what this was like hazing the
Super Bowl winning quarterback they
sliced up his suit so he'd have to wear
his uniform home out of the so I'm there
and Hostetler comes back he's just been
at the podium he goes what the bleep and
I didn't know how to react because he's
looking around gone who did this right
so he held it up and it was just in
pieces sliced up and I linked to this
day the two of the weirdest moments ever
had his OJ Anderson just winning a Super
Bowl yelling right and Hostetler's suit
was sliced up right and like they just
won right it's kind of crazy how
sometimes the reaction happens I mean
the the phrase that I've heard over and
over again having again this is my 16th
Super Bowl I'm covering that I still
never understand by somebody who wins is
no one can ever take this away from me
and I'm like whoa
who's attempting to action come on you
know like who is like no I know who's
gonna try and do that that makes no
sense
we saw on the show uh you are first all
right Tony Boselli is gonna stop by
after he stops by with you yeah um
then we've got Arthur Blank oh nice our
host yeah mr. bull uh Scott zou Lac
we'll stop by as well he's goofy and
it's gonna be fun because uh speaking of
just a quick story when post deflategate
I'm sitting at home watching Sunday
Night Football when Tom came back I
think his first game might have been on
Sunday Night Football or something like
that
or no it was it was he hadn't been
suspended yet opening night was in
Foxborough that's what it was okay right
he had not it was the year later that he
took his suspension okay yeah so um I'd
tweet out hey Brady's always been speak
you always speaks after games if he
doesn't do it this time you know he's
really upset with the NFL so then he did
not speak after the game he ran off yeah
into the locker room and I just tweeted
out there goes Tom Brady running off
into the locker room so and this was
after a year I was pounding the table
how ridiculous deflategate was on my
show every day so Scott Zola and the
rest of the local Oh
people just saw that last week thinking
I was criticizing Brady for running off
the field and the amount of grief he
gave me I've got all the drops to replay
low that he comes I love that it could
be a little awkward but uh that makes
that makes good high quality television
yeah Rich Eisen the Rich Eisen show and
DirecTV audience Network and of course
he'll be there on Sunday morning and I
feel gameday morning starts five minutes
ago your pregame show thank you buddy be
back for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
you
[Music]